si on met un requin dans une piscine le
record du 100 m crawl serait facilement
battu mais comme les requins ne sont pas
admis aux jo les scientifiques ont
étudié la texture de leur peau pour
créer un nouveau maillot de bain très
très sophistiqué l'eau glisse tellement
sur la peau des requins que rien ne les
freine et c'est pour ça qu'ils vont si
vite
les scientifiques ont donc reproduit sur
ordinateur le corps des athlètes comme
pour les tenues de spider man et matrix
ils ont ensuite adapter les combinaisons
pour que rien ne puisse freiner les
sportifs dans leur course mais
évidemment ce n'est pas le maillot qui
fait le champion je ne pense pas que
porter ce maillot soit une façon de
tricher je pense il dans chaque sport il
ya des avancées technologiques et c'est
ça aussi qui rompt le sport si excitant
michael phelps est américain il est déjà
triple champion du monde n'est pas
encore médaillé olympique
alors cette année à athènes avec sa
super combi il va tout faire pour monter
sur le podium mais attention la
concurrence sera rude parce que d'autres
nageurs ont aussi adopté le look requins
du coup retour à la case départ c'est le
meilleur qui aura la médaille